rebound for lopez
westbrook looking here's beal
hanging beale puts it up and in and that
should be the 10th assist
and that will be history it is
he has tied oscar robertson with 181
career triple doubles
and it's bradley beal holiday the pass
deflected by bertons 3.1
seconds on the shot clock
[Music]
this is the history-making assist by
russell westbrook
able to find bradley beal
and beal into the paint converts
for the 10th assist of the game and that
gives russell westbrook 181.
starting that backcourt they want some
momentum mcconnell to levert
and it's blocked by westbrook the
game-saving block
on a night when he makes history
great defensive effort by russell
westbrook took the gamble
i said do not foul a jump shooter but
you know what russell westbrook
had better plans he got the block
shooter
i mean look at this russ showing the
vert test
going up with the left hand
with the clean block
blocking it with the left which is what
you want to do
what a close-out he hits the two free
throws
eight of nine at the line and then he
saves the game
with that block